number 44 being remembered today as the
world series is back in atlanta dusty
and hank aaron played together from 1968
through 1974
and
signs from hank aaron and his legend
lives on throughout not just the city of
atlanta but specifically in this
ballpark all over tourist park ladies
and gentlemen
please welcome to game three of the
world series
billy
aaron
throwing out tonight's ceremony first
pitch we are honored to introduce
hank aaron jr
accompanied by his grandson reynald and
sisters kale and dorinda
catching tonight's first ball is braves
first baseman
freddie freeman
ian anderson can sling it fastball
change-up is what he's known for dan and
the postseason resume already for
someone who is still rookie eligible in
2021 it's elites one-on-one out here's
michael brandley he has had a great
series already and a great postseason
all together he's hitting 352
round ball taken by ian fires the second
they get one there dansby to first place
double play
great play by ian anderson if it gets
through i still think it's a double play
six to three but ian with quick reflexes
standard start of that one six three
double play density coming across the
back from the second base side he's not
too used to that but he handled it just
fine
yeah luis garcia he's era is high but
his biggest game was on the road in
boston it put that series and flipped it
in favor of houston and he's hoping to
do the same thing here in atlanta and
rosario leads things off
for the braves
[Applause]
[Music]
up eddie rosario
and eddie's thinking wait a second
if you want to appeal that's one thing
but there's no way that was a strike
watching the replay in the side angle i
don't think at all
the matt never got out there the body
did but the bat didn't
gotta ask for a little help there tom
arielle the american league batting
champion this year and continuing his
success in the postseason
[Music]
perfect right at the bottom of the zone
that's a great inning for ian anderson
solaire three for nine a home run and a
double two rbis in the world series did
he go around on the pitch downstairs yes
he did says ted barrett at first good
morning good afternoon and good night
jorge solaire
third strikeout for garcia one away
tough slider low and away and that's
what makes him so tough against
right-handed batters when he gets ahead
it's a two out of nobody on for travis
darno no score in the bottom of the
second pretty well to right it sends
back brantley at the wall against the
wall and it's off the brick wall garneau
is on his way to second and he has
himself a two out double the first hit
for atlanta
it's a 16 foot high wall in right field
the last
seven feet
or so of that wall top portion
is brick and that's where that ball hit
and thank goodness for the astros that
kyle tucker raced over toward right
field to to back it up and he's the one
that got it off the carum of those
bricks otherwise
the batter darno would have been on
third base so two down runners at first
and second and hit oh 54 during the
regular season swinging and a miss one
got a breaking ball that bounced and the
inning is over so anderson goes down
brave strand a couple garcia has whipped
four rage with a really good start here
in the bottom of the third inning
looking to score the game's first run
right here first and second nolan out
here comes ozzy
and he got him strike three finally
through the changeup that he had albie's
off stride and it's a big strikeout
fifth strike out of the game for garcia
and there's one away austin riley struck
down back in the first inning this time
down the line of fairball
and the braves are going to score first
tonight
rosario come on down it's one nothing
atlanta a diving attempt by alex bregman
right off the leather of him
down the line kicked off the wall that
by the time jordan alvarez arrived to it
eddie rosario had scored no hits through
three the last pitcher with no hits
allowed through the first three innings
in a world series game i was calling
with tim mccarver and you john come on
alvarez walked correa was hit and tucker
little roller right there to the mound
that'll be taken by ian throws to first
and there's out number three that is not
an easy play
ian calmly approached it halfway between
the mound and the plate bare-handed
delivered a good throw down to freddie
freeman
searching for their first base into the
ball game
and this is a guy you got to be careful
with and julie guriel to lead things off
into the air towards right center field
jorge solaire is there as time
it's under makes the catch one down here
in the fifth better bring maldonado
[Applause]
[Music]
two up two down just like the fourth
inning but
strike three beautiful change-up
strikeout number four for ian
and he has silenced the astros through
five innings break five innings
remain anderson five innings no hits
no runs walk three struck out four hit a
batter he turns it over the bullpen here
in the sixth aj mentor worked two and
two thirds innings in houston in game
one gave up only one run struck out
three
here's bregman he is over one and that's
inside of that head um maybe on the back
leg bregman down on his hands and knees
in some pain and obviously this feels
even worse in the cool conditions
there's a slider that minder just pulled
it looked like the outside of the ankle
perhaps robert yep
and he wears that that mini shin guard
on that front leg but
that hit
on the side
still hasn't put any pressure on it all
right now
he's favoring it a little bit but it
looks like he's going to stay in this
game as he walks down the first base
there are two outs alvarez at the plate
oh for
one alvarez
that is the top of the sticks the astros
still hitless rosario's one for two with
a single walk in the run score it braves
lead one nothing and rosario pokes it in
the shallow center tucker coming on
coming on coming on headlong dive and he
made the catch
excellent play by kyle tucker to take
away a hit from rosario and in the
inning just his fifth start in 2021 in
center field
and that took away a big time hit for
the braves head first that's the
toughest way to dive and tucker was able
to make the catch and not hurt himself
at the same time
correa oh for one with the walk jackson
the scoreless inning in two thirds in
game one correa on one bounce to aldi's
aggressive scoop and throw and
the astros are still hitless well ron
washington somewhere in that dugout a
smile and there he is
they do a lot of work for four games
with that short hop drill ron washington
gets about 10 12 feet away
and he makes ozzie albies catch that
ball out front backhand forehand hits
allowed by the braves a one to nothing
ball game here in the eighth the series
tied at a game of peace led ms diaz off
the bench to pinch it for maldonado and
diaz lifts this one in the shallow left
racing in rosario still coming in and it
drops in front of him and then rolls
behind him but he picks it up before
diaz can think about going to second
base and that's the astros first hit and
it looked like a ball that if rosario
had gotten a better read on would have
been able to catch yeah he did get a bad
jump
rightfully so it was off the end of the
bat on a big swing from
oledmi's diaz jose siri running at first
representing the tying run pitch to
brantley there goes siri the pitch is
low thought in the second by darno hop
and it gets into center field going past
all these and down to third base goes
siri so now the tying runs 90 feet away
with two out
braves leading one nothing bradley
popped up left side dansby and austin
both there austin says he's got it makes
the catch on the foul line
they hang another zero up on the
scoreboard raves have gone down in order
each of the last two innings
have not had a base hit since to all
single the fifth inning well struck by
darno to deep central
forget about it
darneau goes deep again
two nothing atlanta travis
[Applause]
one more out puts this one in the win
column
two nothing braves top of the ninth
runner at first 208
hit in the air to right field duvall
going back so is a radio horizon has got
a room radius got it
it is a two-hit shutout the braves win
and they take game three over the astros
by a final score of two to nothing
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes